okay so yes my name is machi I actually
live in potsdam and I work for rain
forest QA which is a startup based in
San Francisco but today I'm not going to
tell you about any of that and instead
I'm going to talk about part of my
research in computer vision so that's
work that we presented at siggraph last
summer and it's also part of my PhD
thesis and I did it together with
Michael Terry in Waterloo and Gabriel
Roscoe and at UCL in London who was my
supervisor so the basically the problem
we're trying to solve here is how to
turn this image in to this one there was
a shadow and now there is no shadow and
Before we jump in I want to give you a
little quiz if I show you this image can
anyone tell whether this image was
changed in any way i can give you a
small hint that there was a shadow here
that was removed and can you see where
okay in the foreground yep you're right
it was here actually we removed I think
that's the shadow of the Nelson column
in Trafalgar Square so we got rid of the
guy so the what happened here is we got
an image like this together with a
binary mask provided by a user so this
is like a thick brush stroke telling us
which shadow to get rid of and our
algorithm getting that returned this
shadow free image and the cool thing
about it is that now we know or not only
have a image that has no shadow but we
only have also have a shadow match which
is an image like that it's basically a
grayscale image each pixel is between
zero and one and if you multiply shadow
for image with this one you get shadowed
image and if you have shadowed image and
you divide by this one pixel wise you
get a shadow free image and the nice
thing about having that is that now we
can not only remove the shadow but we
can also modify it so what you see here
is just like a simple interface
prototype in in Python and there are
some very simple 2d image editing
operations you can like skew the image
you can change the contrast to make the
shadow soft
sharper and it looks fairly realistic
and it's a nice way to edit your shadows
and we are not the first ones to to
investigate this problem and there are
kind of a couple of related areas I'll
probably skip most of that because we
don't have that much time but there is
lots of interesting work and I one thing
I want to mention is shadow rendering
which is kind of the inverse of what
we're doing which mike to get rid of
shadows but there's also been lots and
lots of research in computer graphics
about how to render shadows how to make
shadows look realistic and add them to
images and we kind of use that as an
inspiration later on so first of all
what are soft shadows so soft shadows
are shadows that have wide penumbra and
penumbra is this region that's not quite
in shadow and not quite out of shadow is
this kind of band of shadow that gets
goes from completing shadow to out of
shadow and as you go out the gets
brighter and brighter so such shadow
side ones with white penumbra sharp or
hard shadows have nothing it's just like
one pixels in shadow the other one auto
show so let's look at a penumbra so here
you have a simple 3d scene you have this
plane and here is just texture less
plane and the light source and just by
the way the whole difficulty in do in
this problem is separating the variation
in lighting from variation in texture so
keep this in mind this is a simplified
solution but it illustrates the problem
and we also have light source above now
if you add an occluder you have a shadow
cast on the ground and we can look at
the shadow as an intensity surface so
that means that if you look at the image
each pixel is again from 0 to 255 and
the higher values are literally higher
and the lower values are lower so you
can look at this slope as the inside the
penumbra and then you can look at 2d
profile so the red line here is just a
2d profile of this ass intensity surface
and you'll notice that it kind of looks
like a function so maybe we can fit a
parametric model to that and that would
be great because then we could
fit the same model two images together
with texture and then we would know okay
this part of the change in color is due
to shadow and the other parts are due to
texture so let's not remove that so
let's try doing that here we have a
third order polynomial a fairly simple
function that just fits just this
profile pretty well and it works all
right not sure you can see very well but
inside the red line there's a black line
the actual fitted function and then we
can use that to on shadow and the
resulted resulting unscheduled image is
the older profile is the blue eye on top
and there are also other functions that
fit well we can try sigmoid functions or
a piecewise quadratic and so on
unfortunately this kind of smooth
sailing ends here because depending on
shape of the light source and a few
other factors this gets very difficult
so we tried hard but we were unable to
find one parametric model that explains
all situations that generalizes so this
was the square lights this is triangular
light and they all have kind of slightly
different properties so if we cannot
solve it in this nice principle
mathematical way we can sort of go on
the other end of the hockey spectrum and
just look at lots and also data and try
to learn how penumbra look like now this
is difficult if you only have real data
because you take millions of images but
as I said the graphics community have
been hard at work trying to figure out
how to create shadows so we can just
render ourselves training set so what
i've done here is i've used my are with
bit of scripting and set it up to sort
of the photorealistic rendering and then
created a i think 10 some tens of
thousands of image pairs one image with
the shadow and the other one without the
shadow and this allows us to use this to
learn the mapping from ok if the
shadowed image looks like this then the
unchartered image looks like that and a
very in texture and like sighs and the
penumbra width and so on so in effect we
have this thing that teaches itself how
to remove shadows and that's pretty cool
and this is the overview of
of how the whole system works I'll go
through it once really quickly just
mentioning each part and then I'll talk
about each each part in detail so first
of all we get an image which is an RGB
image together with this binary mask and
we do two things and does anyone know
what the in Photoshop what is the
content aware fill okay a few people so
basically is this thing that you can you
can take a picture of photo that you
take and you select a part of it and
photoshop photoshop just throws it out
and replace it with something that looks
plausible so if you take out the part of
wall that's pretty simple just fit in
the wall if you take out something more
complicated it won't fill in the same
thing but it will look make it look okay
in most cases so that's the first thing
we do as kind of our initial guess it
has some problems which I'll mention as
well so it's not kind of the solution to
shadow removal but it helps and the
second thing that we do is divide the
whole image into small patches actually
we just take the the red channel of this
image and divide it into small patches
and then we take each patch through our
machine learning pipeline so we compute
the features put it into a run or forest
and get label back in our case the label
is also an image of the same size this
is the patch that contains just a shadow
much in fact from the from the forest we
get a bunch sorry a bunch of patches for
each one location in the image so then
what we need to do is some kind of
regularization you can think of this as
now image where each patch it actually
has moved like a stack of options and
you have to choose one of them and each
location and it gives you the final
match not quite final you still have to
recover the color which we do at the
very end ok so in painting I already
told you what in painting is overall
it's it's a real goofing but it has some
problems in particular it doesn't deal
with structure very well so here you can
see the mortar and bricks is not
reconstructed as well as good and you
can also say okay here like naive in
painting just gets rid of everything but
we actually have a little bit moon from
we know more or less what should be in
the shadow we just need to adjust color
so what we could try to do is guide us
in painting and this is something like
the first thing we try it because it
would be really cool when you actually
the impending algorithms is itself
really cool so we try to modify it a
little bit to try to in paint with a
little bit of similarity to to the
shadowed areas and this guided in
painting works okay but we didn't
realize the beginning that there are
usually pixels in the original image
that are very very similar to the
shadows pixels so it's very difficult to
come up with a distance function that
ignores the shadow but it still still
makes the in painted image looks right
so we can see that the shadows image
don't have a pointer yeah you can see
that the shuttle pixels over here are
very very similar similarly colored to
these pixels which are not in shadow
what is the same material and is just
slightly darker and what ended up
happening we just reconstruct it the
shadow so that's not really what we want
so let's get back to the impending of
the shelf and this image is not great
but it has some good things about it
like the colors are more or less okay
the shadow is gone so we use it as our
initial guess and I also talked about
later how exactly we use it okay the
next step is patch alignment so you've
seen that we have divided the image into
patches and now we take actually let me
just illustrate the point point first we
have our intensity patch it's just part
of the image what we want to do in our
machine learning pipeline is complete
some features over this patch and create
a mapping from these features to our
shadow but now let's look at a different
patch it looks like that we complete
features and get a slightly different
match now as you can you probably notice
these two patches were kind of similar
but to our algorithm they looked
completely differently like if you
vectorize it and take all the all the
pixels in one big vector they these two
patches will be very different because
the shadow orientation is completely
different so we could try to overcome
this problem just by throwing lots and
lots of training data edit but it's not
really feasible because the training
time increases lots and lots
so what we do instead is this patch
alignment step basically we take each
patch and make a small Euclidean
transform so small rotation or in
translation to try to bring it as close
as possible to this template over here
and that just means that every patch we
put in our learning pipeline is oriented
more less the same way and that reduces
the amount of training data that we need
and talking about our algorithm it's not
a standard random forest it's
effectively kind of fancy sounding it's
a data-driven nearest neighbor search in
na new kitchen space so to explain that
better I'll just illustrate a basic
random forest and then how we how we
differ so I'm sure you all know how
random forests work so i won't bore you
with that but basically we have binary
tree with decisions at each node and
after training each of your leaf nodes
has a bunch of training data in it
normally in 10 forest the leaf node
contains like the mean of all the
samples that fell into this leaf node in
our case is slightly different we just
keep indices of all the training samples
that fell in and we don't average them
so once we have a trained forest we take
the intensity punch or other features
computed over this patch and we take it
through the forest and it goes down
until it reaches the leaf node and that
gives us a bunch of suggestions for what
the possible matt can be at this point
and because we have multiple trees we
the number of suggestions actually
increases and the trick here is how to
train this forest you probably notice
that these labels each of these things
is a 16 by 16 image and that's really
high dimensions so how do you how do you
decide how to split the data if you have
classification that's quite easy you can
just do entropy in regression you can
compute there is this formula which we
took from literature you can compute the
log of the determinant of the covariance
matrix and that basically means that if
you have a bunch of samples that are
really spread out your covariance matrix
would be really big
and if there will be close together
it'll be small so if you can take the
determinant of that you are looking to
make splits that will make the
covariance matrix as small as possible
meaning all the samples within will be
similar another problem here is that
computing covariance in higher
dimensions gets really really slow so
what we do instead is PC a principal
component analysis which basically takes
our high dimensional patch and projects
it down to four dimensions however we
only do this at training time to
complete the splits and we keep these
these all patches actually intact as as
the indices in the leaf nodes so a
training we use this low dimensional
signal presentation but a test time we
actually read the full patch so I will
feature vector it's not that complicated
it has a bunch of things in it has a
pixel intensity it's normalized because
it turns out to work better i can also
explain it later and we have gradients
so just finite differences between
different pixels and we have distance
from the from the shadow edge to where
the current patch is so you can imagine
that the things that are deep in the
shadows sort of far away from the edge
will look different than the ones on the
on the edge and we have a predicted
match and the predicted much is this
first guess that comes from in painting
so we assume that our initial guess in
painting is a shadow free image and we
produce a match based on that and this
match is another feature that we give to
the forest to learn how to how to
distinct this determined differentiate
between different patches and I just
look at feature frequency which features
are important and it's kind of cool to
see this these spikes I'm not sure you
like it's not immediately obvious why
they're there but if you think of
patches it probably makes sense that the
pixels at the edge are sometimes more
important the pixels in the middle and
so on so different gradients sort of
have different importance values but all
of them are kind of important and the
really important one is the one how to
see here is this
distance from the edge turns out to be
really so it's not actually feature
importance its future frequency which is
kind of a proxy that's easier to compute
okay so now we have this image which has
multiple Matt suggestions at each patch
in the image and you have to choose the
right one so this is a micro random
field in computer vision and graphics is
it's a really well-known and exploit
problems and there are standard
solutions to it the problem is that
normally you have it have a setup like
this it's a graph and at each point you
have a set number of labels to choose
from so like three or a hundred does
matter but it's always the same and each
label is kind of a class and you have a
defined distance matrix between all the
classes here it's kind of different
because we at each point we can have
multiple and there's sorry different
numbers of labels to choose from and
there is there's no classes so you have
to dynamically compute the distance
between all the nodes sort of as you go
along so we cannot use the standard
solution for mr f which is called graph
cuts instead we use this TR ws3 related
message passing and that's really well
implemented and it works great so now we
that means that we have this this images
kind of consistent so when you're doing
this regularization you choose the
patches based on the neighbors so we
want the patches that you choose at each
point to be consistent with the
neighbors you don't want to see kind of
create artifacts but you also want them
to be similar to it's called the unit
cost to like a constraint and for a
constraint we use this initial gas so we
want to choose the patches from our
training set that are similar to the to
the initial guess but only if they are
chosen by the run low for us right so
the last part this gives you an image
that's a grayscale single channel and we
actually want a RGB shadow much so you
might think that shadows are gray but
they're actually not most of the time
outdoors shadows are kind of bluish
because of the skylight and so on and
depending on situation they might have
slightly different colors so if you just
assume they're gray you'll get
grammatically wrong image so how do we
recover the colors there are a few
things we could do you could try to run
the regression in sort of in three
dimensions to get the shadow mats that
are already RGB patches but it's very
very expensive and there's the whole
reason we did this dimension
dimensionality reduction is because we
cannot deal with higher dimensional
labels so we cannot really do that you
could run this process three times
independently for each match but that
results in image like this you can
probably a little bit there is to be a
shadow here and on the edge there are
these kind of colorful splotches and
these are the places where the shadow
mats from different channels don't quite
a line so what we did instead is looking
at real shadows so this is a shadow map
that was captured like my friend was
standing somewhere I took a picture of a
sidewalk and he went away in a another
picture so this is our shadow man and if
you look at the profile again you can
see that all the color channels behave
kind of their kind of bounce together
they're all anchored at at one and they
go down to different depths but they
have the similar problem so actually all
we need once we have one channel is to
scaling factors one for the green
channel water blue channel and the way
to find this is we do a simple grid
search with this assumption that the
correct shadow mod will not introduce
new colors into the image so it as
you've seen here there are these
colorful splotches so the number of
colors in the image group so with
finding the combination that doesn't
make that doesn't make it grow and it
works pretty well this is the solution
with the sort of simple optimization for
the other color channels so that's the
whole pipeline now I can show you some
more results and also compared with with
other methods and another quiz where was
the shadow
button right and you vote for bottom
left and it was for the center well done
so the shadows here and you can see it's
fairly soft some lamppost on a sunny day
and so our result it's pretty good I
have to say where did it come from I
think it was a lamp or like a bullet on
the street something like that and you
can see that the shadow much we produce
section not perfect it has a little bit
of a few artifacts and it's kind of not
as smooth as it should be but the thing
is that we just want to have a
perceptually convincing image and it's
enough to make the image too good and
other methods don't do as well they do
better on other scenarios but
specifically on soft shadows we tend to
produce better results right yes totally
neither and the reason for that is
basically time when I started this
vitiates you Nance for jazz getting
popular so I thought I'll just go with
the random forest but I think that it
would be an awesome follow up to do
basically the same thing but use the CNN
in that instead of random forest you can
probably do much better so far I'm
unaware of anyone doing that but it's
probably not that difficult actually so
if anyone's to do it go for it some
other results it's kind of the same
story no matter isn't perfect but it's
good enough and other methods don't work
as well and like looking at this is cool
but if you want to actually convince
someone that your method is better than
other matters you have to run a user
study i'll skip this this is just
showing that using the initial guesses
just not as good as it could be right so
we run a perceptual user study we took
50 participants which is not great but
it's better than like 10 grad students
which is kind of used to be a standard
and computer graphics and vision so a
little bit better but there's still a
way to go
and we run an online user study showing
people images and there were two stages
in the study in the first stage we just
show them an image and we didn't even
tell them that it's about shadow removal
we just showed them an unshod hood image
and said do you think this looks natural
kind of like the quiz I gave you at the
beginning is it no it was the image
changed and in the second stage we gave
them an unshod hood image and we gave
them an arrow so showing like okay the
shadow was right here do you think it
was removed successfully or not and they
gave us score is based on that so these
are just these two stages and the first
stage of a kind of ordering the images
that looked more natural to be on top
and the second stage they were just
giving scores per image and this is the
analysis so it is very simple Bayesian
analysis and this is the posterior
probability of a image from given method
winning the ranking so the first round
and ours is blue so we slightly better
than the rest and here's the probability
of winning the second round and then
probably win one image winning both and
so we kind of reliably better than
others but there's still lots of room
for improvement as you can see here
perfect shadow removal pretty low
probability it works better than sort of
previous methods but still not great and
the limitations are first of all we only
deal with soft shadows because hard
shadows was already kind of a soft
problem at that point but a unified
approach would be nice second of all if
in painting fails horribly as it is here
so i asked photoshop to remove this
region and it just in painted this room
and multiple times into the sidewalk and
there's the kind of mistakes that
happens sometimes so if it fails so
badly we don't really recover and we
produce an unscheduled image that
follows that more than it should so
probably coming up with a better guided
in painting method or maybe there's
something else we could do that's
another area where we could improve and
that's basically it so we have this
method that takes that produces and
shadows images and it's kind of evaluate
it fairly well and so on the website you
can find the code for rendering the data
and I didn't get around to putting the
actual code for the algorithm
but it will be there and also the code
from the user study and so on so that's
it thank you very much